[Applaudissements]
sécheresse incendie inondation après un
été de catastrophe naturelle jamais
l'action climatique n'aura été aussi
urgentes cette cop27 est-elle alors
celle de la dernière chance oui répond
le secrétaire général de l'ONU au cours
de cette décennie cruciale la lutte
contre le changement climatique sera
gagné ou perdu la montée des eaux
prédite par le GIEC menace d'engloutir
l'île de bola au Bangladesh 500
000 personnes doivent être déplacées
ce sont les premiers réfugiés
climatiques de l'histoire
ils pourraient être 250 millions en 2050
la paix mondiale est en jeu oh happy day
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
notre maison brûle
et nous regardons ailleurs
nous ne pourrons pas dire que nous ne
savions pas à la cop21 à Paris le coup
de marteau est historique
pour le climat est accepté
195 pays s'engagent à limiter le
réchauffement à 1,5 degrés à la fin du
siècle mais sept ans plus tard la
planète se dirige vers une hausse de 2,8
degrés dans 30 ans l'été en France en
moyenne ce sera 50 degrés je peux vous
dire que ce sera beaucoup beaucoup moins
dérangeant que ce qu'on est en train de
faire d'aller emmerder d'aller en effet
bloquer des personnes dans leur
automobile pendant une demi-heure sur le
périphérique les membres de dernière
rénovation assurent par ailleurs que
d'autres actions d'envergure sont
prévues vous rendez compte que ce jeune
homme dit que dans 30 ans il fera 50
degrés à Paris et que ça motive toutes
ses actions vous rendez compte où on en
est aujourd'hui tu veux que je te joue
quoi bah alors ça change pas de moi
[Musique]
je te propose de rendre l'antenne
là-dessus
ok merci
vous êtes tous des zombies
[Musique]
un mémorial en hommage à Deauville elle
fait de maison de la saga Harry Potter
mais en péril l'écosystème d'une plage
au pays gale c'est à cet endroit qu'il
est enterré dans le film depuis
plusieurs années des fans déposent des
galets peints et des chaussettes
chaussettes grâce à laquelle dans
l'histoire le jeune sorcier libère la
créature de sa servitude aujourd'hui les
autorités demandent au touriste de ne
plus rien laisser derrière eux car ils
mettent en danger la faune et la flore
locale en compromis vient d'être annoncé
heureusement la sépulture de Dobby peut
rester mais désormais la plage est enfin
les chaussettes sont interdites sur
cette plage voilà et un parking payant
bien évidemment va être construit juste
à côté pour accueillir ce flot de
nouveau visiteurs
c'est pas très écolo
de carbone mais c'est extrêmement
spectaculaire et il faut faire attention
la difficulté aussi c'est de tirer droit
parce que si on touche les bottes de
foin c'est trois secondes de périton
elle est sa part les deux Smiths les
deux filles oui oui
[Musique]
Stéphane et kalisson tout va se jouer au
face-à-face le dernier face à face
en réalité
composé de résidus de la production de
vin blanc et de fromage que Charles III
lui-même le pétrole nous sommes obligés
de l'acheter à d'autres chair trop cher
c'est notre richesse qui s'en va et
notre façon de vivre qui est menacée
alors que peut-on faire
et bien d'abord mieux utiliser l'énergie
vous verrez en France on n'a pas de
pétrole mais on a des idées attention
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la surprise ici avec cette sortie de
route terrible terrible
nous devons travailler ensemble on est
dans le même bateau soit on navigue
ensemble soit en coule ensemble
la seule polémique je veux dire il y a
un truc très très drôle moi qui pour moi
est une polémique si vous avez vu en bas
des records d'audience en ce moment et
il y a pas un journaliste media qui le
reprend sur Twitter j'adore il y a plein
de journalistes je regarde et à chaque
fois ils prennent toutes les audiences
de tout le monde sauf Touche pas à mon
poste si j'en parle jamais c'est
extraordinaire ça ça me fait beaucoup
rire mais continuer les chéris je vous
dire on continuera à faire de millions
et tout va bien se passer